that [ __ ] is great the only bad part is  you cannot  pass out around white people every time  white dudes  pass out around each other they always  do some borderline gay [ __ ] when the  guy's asleep  frank fell asleep so we like stuck a  carrot in his ass and  put shaving cream on his balls like why  a [ __ ] why would you do that to  a friend of yours he trusted you enough  to sleep around you're gonna put a  carrot in his ass that is that nice  i tell you right now if i put a carrot  in a black dude that [ __ ] will kill you  when he wakes up for some [ __ ] like that  that is an automatic  death sentence on the street  it's a wrap for you i'm gonna kill that  [ __ ]  [Applause]  i thought y'all was friends baby  what happened  i i fell asleep at this house right we  was drinking and i fell asleep at this  house and and while i was sleeping right  i'm just gonna kill that [ __ ]  all right that's all you need to know